[Music]
[Applause]
now then serious stuff three attacks in
the past week in Germany all involving
migrants first the axe attack on the
train that injured four a machete attack
after a fight or a dispute with one
woman hacked to death and just last
night an Isis suicide bombing outside a
music concert Rob Spencer is with us he
is the director of jihad watch Robert
welcome to the program thank you I get
the distinct impression and so to our
viewers that the pace of these incidents
is speed is really speeding up it is and
it's going to get worse this is just the
beginning we have to remember that the
Islamic State or Isis has repeatedly
declared its intentions of sewing just
this kind of Mayhem in the west
repeatedly called on Muslims in the west
to mount Jihad Terror attacks Lone Wolf
attacks they threatened in February 2015
they actually warned that they were soon
going to flood Europe with 500,000
refugees that doesn't mean all the
refugees are jihadis but that there is a
significant number of jihadis among the
refugees cannot be denied this has been
an active infiltration effort that has
been wildly successful then Angela
Merkel who invited them in open the door
September of last year I think it was 2
million come on in open the borders that
was a disastrous mistake for Europe and
certainly for her that would have been
tantamount to saying on December 8
1941 we invite any citizen of the
Japanese empire to come and settle in
the United States there is a state of
war between Isis and the west and the
West is pretending that the war doesn't
exist and enabling it to enabling the
enemy to advance what about us here we
want to take in I don't know the exact
number but I'm told it's around 880,000
Muslim migrants largely Muslim migrants
from North Africa they they want to
bring them in here what do you say to
that that is gu guaranteeing that there
will be more Jihad massacres like we saw
in Orlando and San Bernardino here
remember that tashin Malik the San
Bernardino Shooter had passed five
separate background checks from five
different US government agencies they
all saw nothing in her background and
she was an Isis operative she's not
alone they're going to be plenty more
like her and briefly I just want to go
back to Europe uh Pope Francis is
visiting Poland Wednesday of this week I
believe the polls want to keep out these
migrants the pope wants more of them in
on humanitarian grounds what do you make
of this the pope is inviting the suicide
of Europe the pope is actively enabling
the suicide of Europe but he's acting as
a humanitarian let's remember 3,000
migrants have drowned in the
Mediterranean just this year Saudi
Arabia has thousands of air conditioned
tents for the pilgrims that lie unused
all but 10 days of the year they could
take in all of those people and they
have a cultural linguistic and religious
bond with them that Europe does not have
why don't they take them in they will
not take them in because they freely
acknowledge that there are terrorist
among them which if we say we're charged
with racism and bigotry and islamophobia
give give me the end game here if as you
say these events speed up they get more
common constantly almost what's the end
game for Europe is it civil Strife what
is it I don't see how civil Strife can
be avoided this is going to be happening
on a regular basis now in Germany and
it's going to spread to the other
countries and at certain point people
are going to fight back you have just
written the complete infidels guide to
Iran is that correct correct is it
published yet it is available now from
Regner publishing at any self-respecting
bookstore self-respecting
bookstore you got it in nicely Robert
Robert Spencer everyone the complete
infidels guide to Iran thank you sir
thank you much obliged